we understand you're writing a book on
crowdsourcing yeah and it should be out
in 2015
probably yeah hopefully by the American
film market in 2015 yeah okay bifocal
press eye focal press it's part of a new
imprint for them the American film
market presents so there's a few titles
that they're gonna launch this year and
this is one of them
okay um what's the difference though
between crowdfunding and crowdsourcing
good question this is the question that
comes up all the time so I tell people
I'm writing a book about crowd sourcing
they immediately think crowdfunding
crowdfunding of course is you know
getting people to donate to a project
we're gonna keep it in film to your film
project you set a goal you go out and
market yourself you know you set up a
Kickstarter page IndieGoGo page and you
have people donate to the cause within
crowdfunding there is an element of
crowdsourcing crowdsourcing is all about
identifying the crowd engaging a crowd
and moving a crowd so for example let's
say let's stay inside the realm of a
crowdfunding campaign one of the case
studies have a book in the book is a
documentary called the mile mile and a
half okay mile mile and a half was about
five cinematographers and a sound editor
who decided that they they're all health
enthusiasts as well they decided they
were going to hike the entirety of the
John Muir Trail which is like 206 miles
and film it and record it like the
different ecosystems the whole entire
thing to show it in its natural beauty
now on the surface that doesn't sound
like a broad base like something that
everybody in the mothers gonna want to
watch but what they did and this was
three to six months before they even
started the campaign was they went out
and they started engaging hikers health
enthusiasts camera peep you know people
that were into camera equipment and
sound equipment and things of that
nature cinematographers and and things
of that nature
filmmakers and said here's what we're
looking to do and started a campaign on
on Facebook and on Twitter and all the
social media and you know got people for
example - what's your favorite trail to
hike how long we've been hiking do you
have any tricks of the trade when you're
a little hiking overnight when you
camping what do you do things of this
nature and they built a community that's
crowdsourcing okay they identified a
crowd and they started engaging the
crowd but it's time that they were ready
to go hike and then you know even start
this campaign and they were going for an
eighty five thousand dollar raise which
is a lot of money right especially for a
documentary you know and this kind of
documentary they had already had about
forty thousand followers on Twitter or
likes on Twitter however many I mean on
Facebook I'm sorry I have having many on
on Twitter and they had engaged all
sorts of bloggers bloggers who wrote
about hiking bloggers who wrote about
the outdoors you know so on and so forth
all of a sudden some of these people
went to outdoor gear companies and said
hey you should check out what these guys
are doing and all of a sudden they were
getting gear donated to them camera
equipment donated them all this stuff
started happening before they even
thought about putting the campaign line
that's crowdsourcing that's the first
two steps of crowdsourcing identifying
the crowd engaging crowd asking them
questions getting them involved getting
them engaged they were posting videos
all the time about what they plan to do
on the trail pictures from the trail you
know those people are taken they got
people who had already hiked the trail
to put up their videos and stuff like
that
when the time came for them to start
promoting the Kickstarter campaign they
went to the crowd and they said okay
we're ready now we're gonna ask would
you support this project the money came
flowing in okay
everybody wanted to be involved because
they had taken the time to identify and
engage and now they were asking them to
move so it's all about that's exactly
what crowdsourcing is and you could do
that for anything when it comes to a
film you could do that four locations
you know you could do it four characters
you know I'm doing this film and this is
the subject of the film and maybe the
subject of the film is you know children
with autism so you go to a group and you
say you know this is this is what the
film was about this is what my character
is about who would like to name the
character like you know these are these
are the the names that we've come up
with in the main character like vote for
a and now all of a sudden is an
engagement you know this is an
involvement
that's crowdsourcing and so the book you
know covers all aspects of crowdsourcing
social media crowdfunding networking
offline you name it it's got five or six
case studies in it ranging from shorts
to features to documentaries and even
you know what stage 32 there's a little
part about that and there because we've
crowd-sourced the site from day one the
you know the first day that I opened the
doors to this thing I went to a hundred
of my friends and I said take a look at
it tell me what you like and what you
don't like so that's immediately crowd
sourcing okay because I'm asking you to
you know and here's some features I was
thinking about adding you tell me if you
think they're good or if you have other
suggestions okay
but the bigger ask was if you like what
we're doing if you like this concept I
would like you to go out and invite five
fellow creatives that you know minimum
okay and I'm gonna ask them to invite
five you know five more people minimum
we've been doing that since day one
we've never paid for advertising we've
never done any you know outward
marketing you know outside of our own
promotions and the idea at events and
things of that nature we have four
hundred thousand people on the site and
it's just because people invite
thousands sometimes hundreds thousands
dozens you know whatever at a time
people will invite their entire cast and
crew people invite the entire acting you
know class sort of you know
screenwriting group or whatever that's
crowdsourcing it's getting them engaged
making them understand making them a
part of it and then ask them to go carry
the message so the intention of
crowdsourcing
isn't always to then launch a
crowdfunding campaign no no okay
but there is an element of crowdsourcing
within every crowdfunding campaign and
that's about cultivating the audience we
talked earlier about crowdfunding and we
talked about the the idea that a lot of
these campaigns fail not only because
you don't have a marketing plan before
you start any good crowdfunding
campaigns should have a three to six
month you know launch or ramp up I
should say before you launch but it's
approach you see when again we go back
to that idea of hey you as opposed to
would you you know would you like to be
involved
this can I give you ownership of kind of
what we're doing can I make you feel
like you're a part of it you know going
back to the mile mile and a half example
you know here's this hiking
Cinematography nature you know hybrid
when the film premiered at the LA felt
first glance Film Festival they had to
open up a second so many people showed
up they'd open up a second theater that
never happened before in the history of
the festival and it was because all
these people have been so engaged so
long that they couldn't wait to see it
because they felt like they were a part
of it it was a year and a half journey
to the screen and they were there every
step along the way you know what I mean
and they felt pride and ownership in
that they sold a bajillion you know DVDs
at the festival the movie ended up being
number two on iTunes in the documentary
section behind hero Dreams of Sushi
which has been up there forever and you
know I mean it was all because they
moved the crowd and the crowd supported
it from the crowdfunding campaigns that
you've watched from afar or even
supported but involved in how many what
percentage would you say don't have an
idea about how to crowdsource
they know how to pull that trigger and
launch that campaign and say me me me
Here I am
donate but they're not that great at
cultivating a community 90% okay I mean
it's a high number it's a lot of people
just don't get it and you know again
it's that if you build it they will come
mentality then it just does not work in
you know my work with products you know
you said like the Pebble watch or
something like that like it might work
with a product because people are so
awed by and say oh I want one of those
but with a film the competition is so
fierce for your eyeballs there's so many
crowdfunding campaigns and if you are
popular on social media you are getting
inundated with people saying look at my
campaign look at it look at it look at
it it's the people that say hey I'm
doing the movie on that and you know
that's cool and we out with it well you
know we're probably six months out from
even pre-production but this is what
we're going to do and I happen to notice
that you you know it's a movie about
baseball I understand you're a baseball
fan
y-you know what's your favorite team you
know you're cultivating that
relationship even if it's not just doing
it directly to me one-on-one but doing
it to your whole entire group and asking
those questions you know and getting
them involved it makes such a difference
that but it's not when you finally get
to that point when you're ready to
launch and you finally make what we call
the ask you know you haven't asked for
anything before you've asked questions
of me you know about me about my likes
and everything like that you haven't
asked me for anything and now of course
I'm gonna be more engaged and more
likely to support you because you not
only identified the fact that I like you
know that I am your target audience but
you've done it in a way that makes me
feel engaged and connected to you so I'm
much more likely to support you as
opposed to hey you
you